afternoon all I'm with my good friend
Chris chess explained so we have another
game of the day pick which we've picked
our between us hi Chris yeah try it on
high we're a bit late for the second
round but we didn't manage yesterday on
my part that was due to the euro 2012
football competition of course and so I
couldn't do any chesser yesterday ok so
let's let's get going I think we have
four Kramnik against crucial here yeah
that's our choice of the careful and
detailed consideration of other games ok
so there's this wasn't think so kramnik
as white played night f-free rehti
starting offers might a free
non-committal four pawns just like a
free yeah yeah kramnik mixes d4 Knight
f3 usually Anissa in his games he starts
d4 Knight f3 just according to to his
opponent hmm um I think he really plays
an idea three with the intention to to
get some independent opening that can
only arise from Knight f3 there let's
say just for instance yeah after this he
always plays d4 and returns to usual d4
structures he never almost never plays
stuff like this year so he uses Knight
f3 as a transpositional tool you know to
avoid certain lines and then the main
avoidance serious said the groom felt
and the name so Indian very often he
places against people who against his
spec sir to play the gruene felt and
maybe he's not he has got an excellent
score against the groom father you need
to know this it's not like he's not he's
not doing well again this opening but I
think he likes to mix them with his
stuff and uncertain days wants to avoid
certain variations and so idea through
this time I grease truck has a wide
repertoire so it's hard to guess what
you would play
has in the mini match they had last year
in the candidates in kazan russia we
shock always played c-5m right and they
get got this kind of this kind of
opening yes he accepted the d5 whole I
think I video edit 81 of grids gypsy II
crush kamsky with black seemingly
effortlessly he accepts the d5 Holland
gets a good Kings i'll attack sometimes
yeah yeah this line he played quite a
lot and in this candidates tournament
but this time he does something else and
something which well at least surprised
me a lot so yeah let's go on ya thing
Knight f6 and then we headed straight to
the Kings Indian so seafood g6 yes and
now um so nicely free so sort of Kwazii
groom fields d5 it doesn't really work
for black hair does it d5 hair yeah it's
a satisfactory but it's so just another
opening its and of course it resembles a
green felt but it can be quite different
I'm the White has a huge choice yet this
is also maybe one of the reasons why
sometimes blacks players some don't want
to go into this because white has so
many interesting lines here you can try
just for instance you can play play this
line which is interesting you can of
course capture here and now he's got so
many moves you can play k for queen
queen bees actually who in Queen I fool
can we just quickly touch from this
Queen I for ya this looks quite
dangerous I say night so it knows it's a
c6 then Queen d4 might be good LC 6 on
c6 um I'm not sure that this is so
dangerous or maybe not okay I mean f6
black hand play of six a non c 6 white
usually takes on d5 all right I mean
it's possible and now you fall on the
queen is covering for from the side and
then you follow up with g4 right it's a
bit like green field but it's not you
don't have this exchange on c3 happen so
it's a little bit of
Joe a difference in the center so it's
it's huge Choi so i can give this check
it he can go for this move he can go to
Paul off-screen see to play even h4 here
which is not entirely pointless really
going age five Queen a 42 h form is
quite crude but it's not that bad oh
yeah it's it's very much very much
choice if a wide so this is also i think
my black players sometimes don't like
this so much but the the king's indian
it was a huge surprise at least for me
gru shock played this before i think but
it's not one of his main main openings
in krum [ __ ] known to have a brilliant
score against the Kings Indians yeah
even against Kasparov he's got a plus
school against Kasparov in King's engine
yeah Kasparov I think never won one a
classical game in the king's indian
against Romney and he lost quite some
yeah he wasn't so bad out of the
openings if i remember correctly but
somehow it didn't work out and it was
really in the early stages of chrome
leaks careered so i'm going to mid 90s
or something yeah because Kasparov
pretty much gave up the Kings Indian
after those losses hmm so I'm blimey I
didn't know is that that was saying yeah
I think he lost two or three and he lost
one brilliant rapid game which is maybe
one of the most impressive rapid games I
ever saw a crumb Nick what against
Kasparov and I he lost quite quite a
number of number of games he won also
one or two rapid games but all in all it
was pretty bad score yeah alright so we
go e4 here and therefore we got the
Kings Indian yeah I think this is a very
normal Castle snow I Kramnik pretty much
always placed the classical line here
yep I used to relish playing black here
but unfortunately there's a horrible
move coming up which I don't
particularly like playing against call
the Burnett attack which is
unfortunately played a lot now isn't
that be four yeah this has become
become the main line maybe over the
years well of course has acquired a
number of moosian move nine but before
as has become the most popular move and
this is some largely due to yeah if you
look at this now wyd what is the
drawback of before here the drawback is
some little like a key sorry the
diagonal sometimes with knowledge
sometimes black news the diagonal the
weekly learning yeah right and night hyf
is actually the main point here which is
also played in the game yeah and this is
also why this move was a bit out of
fashion for four years because it was
thought that night h5 to afford this
kind of ideas would give black good play
and usually um what happened starting in
the mid nineties was that white um began
to play this little move rookie one here
and this really revolutionized this
whole system the idea was basically that
if black goes night f form which isn't a
good move really but them i shall i'm um
okay it's it's playable if black plays
something like that's h6 or something
but f5 would be the normal kind of stuff
you play in the king's indian then white
can actually take em play a five and
distributes the big idea of rookie one
that white can break through in the
center and this position is close to
losing for black yes you're really
little Annika is blank yeah you get c5
also see five yeah Bishop to c4 and then
you're close to exploding on the e-file
I actually had this in the tournament
game once was very funny okay so um yeah
so neither for is bad so usually black
black go some ups and e2 I think funny
in that you won quite quickly you're
fired was was nice to play so then it
always went f5 I need to show this
because it's relevant to the game um 95
and this is a huge difference to
lots of other lines and the classical
Kings Indian worldwide snide sometimes
goes on in this kind of root on ID to
hear it's going to to to g5 and this is
the difference because might often can
get its night to e6 which is very
irritating and this usually continues
like this I to have sixths back because
it was hanging on age five and then why
dumb of course he can play f3 which was
done quite a number of times but also in
the beginning of the line wide was
playing this move right all right and
you need to keep this position in mind
because what we get in the game is quite
similar damn so if you get if we go back
to the game and also Fisher on his
run-up to the 1970 too much Denis it was
it time love he had similar Kings engine
variations well yeah 8am enough time
enough played on move nine not before
but Bishop t2 all right we should i do
but is this is quite similar in a way
because this night age 5 + f5 is also
possible there and white has got this
ideas of nigeria news but would you keep
in mind where did you hide this line
here writers played rookie one and he's
played this my g5 and you should try a
three year and now let's return to the
game here Kramnik play in g3 yeah which
is the old move actually which was
played before rocky one right was
popular and now we got an f5 no chief I
very similar right back and now usually
wide prepaid in the beginning of this
line like 20 years ago it's the play
today but this was actually f3 was the
main move yes and then it can continue
night h5 back and so on I don't know it
in detail but white played this f three
moo moo but now from Nick played
actually we should be a three and now
you see this is very similar to the
position before the only difference
being that the look is back on you on f1
mmm and white has pledged III and this
is I think quite interesting because g3
is quite a useful move as it gives
the bishop a nice retreat square on g2
and it's questionable if the rook is so
great on you one when he wanted to
protect see form which is useful because
this is of course a point where the both
sides are fighting for but the look on
everyone also protects f2 yes she can
get sometimes vulnerable in the long run
at least if it's ND 1 f 2 is much weaker
so i think this is quite interesting at
some it's similar to to this other line
but also a little bit different and I
think um my first impression at least I
think it's quite favorably different I
just like crawling into the fianchetto
variation manually that's his fin
chattering the bishop manually yeah I
it's a bit like that jeez free is just
useful and it gives the square on g2
yeah and it sort of stabilizes the
position mmm and in general what what
what's happening here is right we'll
we'll lend his night only six I think I
need to get rid of a couple of those
signs why don't need sue wants to get to
e6 p.m. yeah therefore getting the
bishop pair because black of course
needs to take it and then potentially
this this bishop here can get over can
get very strong if the d5 pawn goes to
e6 white captures here and then this
diagonal yeah gets into play some and
also of course you got frontal pressure
on d6 which as this game shows that can
sometimes be increased with moves like
this so d6 can be a become a problem if
your pawns here yeah I think all in all
this is some I don't know I think if I
would play would have black ok I would
be quite annoyed about this kind of
setup because you don't get any attack
on white skin or something which you
often have in the Kings Indian where you
push the pawns and get some use some a
check in return that you don't have that
here and somehow it just looks to me at
least that why does pressing and like
has I don't know very few chances to to
get some counter plate it's a game
changer it's like it's like White's
asking a dog to play fetch because
you're giving that pool
saying go and eat it you know so Blatz
gonna have to spend time eating that
porn and it can be a powerful porn suck
anyway even if it's taken yeah I think
we should progress a couple of mustard
show this because it happens quite
quickly that that this this zone night
lens now so yeah Bishop g2 very nice for
people acting move anyways face it so
beautifully you know the night's not
going to go back here it is going to go
for this getting the bishop pair so
positional sort of porn sacrificing
effects isn't it yeah in the long run
this pawn on d6 can easily get lost it
can get attacked most most often it gets
lost in this way that like protects g6
year and then this kind of maneuver but
I used to think I think is that Fisher
match that match you know that black
might be doing okay once you get to porn
you know what is it you know you get a
good Center as well but that this this
has changed my perception of things
quite significantly this single game and
sure about this e six porn yeah I mean
this is some these kind of positions are
difficult to play I had those kind of
positions also myself a couple of times
and with wide of course and I noticed
it's difficult to play i also had games
web exempli got the porn and well ran
away with it and I was asking myself and
what do we have for this porn yeah it's
it's really difficult it's not like
clear-cut better for white or something
yes but white has got nice chances based
on the bishops and the pressure that
will come up yeah so what did I think we
should played a little bit differently
here it didn't capture with llegue de
took here so I'm not sure maybe 98 was
an idea I'm really yeah to get to this
porn but I mean we can we can show show
a bit here the question is what would
would ply white play now I guess be five
but it's not not the only move
did the idea being if black tries to
keep it close then white can take here
and open up just yeah this diagonal very
very nicely so this cannot be the answer
so if black goes here then that's a
question what what what we'll be doing
now moves like Queen a form can be an
idea on night 2 a 3 a bishop 2 to a 3 so
you know hard to tell I think it's all
okay quite nice but it's not so easy to
decide between those moves even c5 might
be an idea here could also be an idea
hmm yeah immediately a checking here Oh
blimey like 27 may be queen d 7 i'm not
sure now okay i know i don't think black
a check and play Knight f6 but you can
maybe go here it's also an idea to
protect the spawn 444 one more move you
know and then continue with let's say
here White has lots of fresh and center
it's very annoying yes um it's difficult
maybe this is this is better I think
somehow this 94 strikes me as being a
bit too yeah accommodating in a way what
did hard to tell crucial certainly knows
what he's doing so let's let's have a
look what happened yeah and now if I
first not taking on it's really only the
best is very dual purpose because if you
will know sorry that C sinks is on the
fire and Bishop a free is potentially
facilitated or maybe after a fall but
even you know if white plays Queen a
full that's jewel purpose as well it
protects this and it puts more pressure
on c6 so sort of attacking and attacking
opportunities a lot is created by b5
that is subtle some of its quite subtle
or maybe not myself yeah yeah wide wide
open
lines and opportunities for his pieces
and the main point is is this ugly penis
yeah 17 it's just hindered by the spawn
and like what would love to somehow or
get this piece into play but it's it's
not easy to accomplish as we see in the
game so um is dd5 is really asking for
it didn't like d5 but if they broke up
says is day 5 really asking for trouble
yeah i'm not sure i mean i'm not sure
what what exactly white-white reply is
got more than one there may be
interesting idea maybe bishop are you
free yeah the question is we should be
three and played immediately or I mean
if you go Bishop a 3 here hmm um what
what should Black Plague how to take it
we should show it really this is the
zoster yeah yeah just this is the
problem the special a 3some our pin
spins the pawn on d5 it cannot move
because of assemblies hanging and well
should like plane out of this is the
basic threat is just taking all these
Hebner taking on d5 clinically Bishop f6
yeah okay and maybe
interesting the questions maybe maybe we
could quit go something like this here
there is to possess persist that this
pawn cannot move this deep or if you if
you any it you cannot move them on
because you fall then you fault and it
opens up everything and now why just
just piles up on the deep own yes a with
rook rook 81 this kind of stuff yeah and
it's not it's not nice no but it's it I
think I'm not even sure that this is the
most exact way to do it the d5 is the
principal move so you may the Sun was an
idea still because it I think if you
look at the game this rookie somewhat
somewhat strange on the six it's the
point form for concrete play by wide so
and f6 was played yes now we recaptured
the corn finally yeah yeah Black has one
upon now this is Unix porn is gone pure
positional don't sacrifice at this stage
just maybe intuitively thinking he's got
pressure or he's back to that with quite
a lot of calculation or a little bit
calculation it look it just looks
visually Blackstock target d6d fall
Brooks and I come to the things a good
night yeah yeah thing if I mean the
practical problem also here in this
position is I'm not quite sure about the
objective merit of the position yet why
does really not really better or
whatever but just think about the yeah
the ease of whites moves you just place
the most active and and optically
pleasing moves like Bishop e3 rook to d1
it's very very easy to come up with with
a good plan as white yeah you've got all
those those attacking a points where you
can put pressure on you and legis stuck
with strange pieces
and it's difficult to coordinate this
now you got the bedroo ship you get a
potentially we King and so on it it adds
up here yeah some a difficult a
difficult position to play you also but
this is just a suspicion I think that's
all preparation of course yeah if you
look at the clock time so when we should
spend half an hour here and Kramnik just
15 or 16 minutes it was very very
quickly playing this so you know it's
possible that this was the preparation I
mean move 13 14 I mean the day they
could have made this pretty quickly but
look f6e 6 I think it was most likely a
known position at least sucram neck you
know yeah I hope I hope only joke Romney
because of rish Joker well purposefully
went into this its request strange quite
strange saw a choice I would say okay so
what did you play um I mean I looked at
the game but if I he for now now we get
this pin against the Queen so that pulls
not going anywhere and it's going to be
undermined very shortly with that night
is defending the port that night it's
going to be attacked soon ah but first
he takes on d5 okay what taking is
interesting isn't it dragging the other
pulling away and leaving that just not
not not biting any of black spawns but
this d5 is fragile now isn't it yeah i
mean whites basic idea here is some I
mean the basic ideas may be in the wrong
expression it's it's it's just what
happens in the position wyd will go
Bishop to a three yeah and somehow this
is a polite but the transposition here
will be that this in this bishop will
actually be exchanged for the night yes
and white and the process will get the
porn back here and at the end of all of
this yeah it comes down to the
difference between this piece and this
piece and porn islands if you look why
will have 12 porn islands one over here
and black with free porn Islands these
two this one and these two this Bishop
blockaded by that porn but more porn
islands and d5 is strategically
important for white for the default
entrance on d7 anyway yeah and this is
this Bishop only for is just a beautiful
piece of the deep on vanishes from the
board because it puts pressure towards
the king yeah yeah have you drew drew
drew both yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
very very nice piece on you Father I
think we're witnessing here a positional
masterpiece it's quite a good advert for
the white side of the bayonet attack
this game is like a model game I think
we're witnessing in it yeah it's a sort
of her what what is it that why does
aiming for in this in this opening and
yeah kramnik put this on the board but
ok so it's played so many model games
against the Kings Indian you can yeah
yeah so okay so um queen bee free queen
bee free interesting isn't it so clearly
free unblocks to porn just in case
there's gonna be undermining of this
porn maybe it creates a pin there as
well just in case yeah I mean and you
need to get the spawn back after all mmm
so um get also um yeah as you said at
the depend on on this rukon 260 it's a
nice a nice multipurpose move also yeah
and roughly six looks very artificial
route b6 putting the rook there yeah I
mean it's really a position I don't know
it's it's difficult what what should
what should black play here hi Brooke
what was wrong with our route de six
just runs in special a free yeah and
then if here you just maybe just take
and then you get you take d5 yeah you
get immediate it's good it's good let's
get shoulders okay let's show this
actually so rupees switch my free
because it shows the this kind of
configuration you're quite nicely so why
would take him
this kind of position this is just a
nightmare for black where whites
threatening actually I'm immediately
looked you six winning Susie she got it
looks brilliant and tactically it's
brilliant isn't it g6 convert examples
just terrible yeah and you've got this
kind of put piece on g7 against the
monster honey form yeah just terrible so
this is actually what white is aiming
for and if you look at the game it's
it's actually what you got in the game
at the end of all this so okay rook to a
rook to be six some but yeah hard to
suggest to move freely I'm not sure I
taking time for I for so so Bishop a
free without any holding up this this
part of the chain more with the Eiffel
porn but play free delayed lil man yeah
and also one idea could be if the
diagonal gets open to to get to get to
the b7 pawn yeah yeah this is so this
works very nicely together yes and yeah
hard to suggest what did you play a six
year and then we see finally bishop IE
free so it's really on the one in that
d5 now here so black plate I be but what
other alternatives okay if he plays d4
be disaster i guess in some way I mean
you can you can win win material with
this move and this is quite enough I
think rook rook f6 here yeah well be 700
be seven years just like don't be
something oh yeah yeah and this shows
you know this this would obsess I mean a
move like this year you cannot take on
essex at all but you could take your
places this yeah this is this isn't what
you want to pin your hip ish appear to
go for a self pin but you can you can
actually just just just go back here and
I just much better yeah these pawns are
menacing with these bishops pointing
down yeah terrible you know yeah okay so
this isn't this is impossible and maybe
you know a queen wolf also Queen f7
looks strong as well you know attacking
these points maybe what does black do
here just queen upset Oh odds are not
bad yeah not bad to torture said this
year ah what are you doing what do you
plan to take you my damn i'd have this
this strange the move and you suppose
you could play Bishop g6 in queen bee
sevens a check is that is that too
greedy giving black boot camp laser I'm
not quite sure I think you lost a bit of
the coordination yeah but mmm yeah but i
think the other line was sometimes it's
good to be just greedy with Bishop c5
and win material yeah well it's looks
looks quite lost actually Lucy five yeah
okay so what did you play a queen move
I've sort of forgot i do youtube app
then we have this exchange against the
d5 and now yeah we're close to the
dimension configuration yeah with those
two pieces actually i don't know how to
do this and with the software this
before should get get a green square and
this is a red square and yourself it's
such a possible not quite sure how to do
this you know but this is just a dream
piece on you form here absolutely so
porn islands blacks got free porn
islands now if we can get this porn back
but also so there's we got a pin here
against this rook we got a pin here
against that pole which is important so
what a black play here um thinking a bit
before him
okay what else was there if he didn't
play be four what white do or book black
do here so he can't take on a for you
just take it in turn be six if you don't
play be four right let's just say maybe
rock the age or something okay what is
is argument's sake hmm I think that's a
good move here with a five maybe ah this
is this is very strong I think let's say
if Blackwood would play something like
this you can take on d5 and take be
seven right and if we 74 also
combination of this bishop and this pawn
means you get a new queen and it's very
very close to this now I just like
obvious get the pool back and then go
pressure yeah yeah this is quite
diagnosis here hmm something like this
rook somewhere here and like entries on
the day porn just just promotes here
this was the complete Quincy 45 I live
too hey I owe you can you can try but I
just need to protect this because it's
just a 1-1 move threat here just not
this many yeah yeah this this bishops
not really healthy yeah thank you paying
a peacetime this Fisher is really
helping things like this porn yeah all
right let's go back to the line then so
he plays be four and now a five ok a
five um so if this wasn't being pinned
this porn then a B would actually be a
threat at the moment its potential
threat if this is uh protected this rook
which black needs to bear in mind but
here he he doesn't move the rook he kind
of pins so we've got two pins going on
it's quite
yeah exactly Queen f7 is so the tricky
tricky kind of move to yeah to pit the
rook on d Pfeiffer against Queen but
right has a strong response ramnik plate
h4 right yes sort of happy times but no
totally justified by this Bishop which
is strategically a lot better than this
bishop so tactics are being justified by
strategy in this position is fantastic
this h4 is that because either just one
thing I think you have some sort of I
don't know um the idea that move like
uslike h4 our bed in a way yeah I'm not
sure this hecka tech thing it's the
usually don't know those flank pawn
moves like a 4-h form yeah they're often
very useful strategically you're very
often because they gain space they sort
of do some um yeah work against gone
from asians and so on it's not it's not
an attacking move I mean age five is
sort of an attack but very often those
flag moves are very very useful him
you've been improving your position hmm
so it's a famous saying that that Larson
bent laws and said if he has no other
idea in a position you would play a 4-h
for me really yeah yeah that's great Oh
your head I didn't know about it you
know a little quotes don't you I didn't
know that quote that's brilliant
fantastic yeah and he actually did you
in his games to use the flank pawns very
often and they're very often effective
in in attacking but also improving your
position as it gains space and yeah okay
okay here here concretely h5 is just
threatened yes and we get an exhaustive
don't wait from black yeah the sauce h
by force a real lemon but out there yeah
but but just this position was just
terrible i know i mean i mean you should
show what happened because it's the
finishing move is very aesthetic in an
aesthetically pleasing yeah yes should i
it's basically pleasing I've had someone
has got me on that before heard
scientist is we're taking good
physically pleasing Queen D 1 so now
this is really on the carbs now because
this rooks potatoes also this is now on
the cards because this pawns now pins
pin and count spin so he's unpinned is
rook as well not that so there's also
potential rook d7 as well pinning the
bishop this this game is features a lot
of pins doesn't it yeah and this also
shows this quindi one this position
shows perfect harmony and whites pieces
hmm somewhat everything protects each
other the Queen everything protects and
everything's working nicely together
yeah this is actually um you know I'm
back from the early nineties always been
a fan of chrome Knicks games and his if
everything worked so for him in the game
they often look like this every piece is
working together and it's sort of form
so i don't know a complete picture of a
game which is flowing from one to the
end as this is one of those it's like
watching brazil football and its peak
brazil very cool nated team yeah was out
of everything everything's played
together yeah this uh this is just very
nice I mean h5 was of course not not the
best move no Navin but what what what
could he play it's not it's not easy at
all no there's some songs hectic soaking
actually I think there's rook da isn't
there just discovering an attack on the
Queen yeah so yeah rook takes da Queen
takes f7 without black humming and Venus
always nice you cannot cannot play this
if you play this I think we can just
play just rook here threatening again
check and try to win a queen or Bishop
d5 so if the blood brooke has to move
here doesn't it yeah let's say it goes
here so two check check alright
protective great oh no hang on it's not
so clear-cut then is it it's very good
for white but maybe we even have
something better okay I have an idea I
have an idea just just take this back
what whatever play this first if you let
kept just now is there was like a
tremendous then this is over
because you cannot go to h7 now and then
and then an end for example you've got
Bishop define showing you exactly fine
ouch it's a very very loud ouch so yeah
and if they cannot take on on h5 it's
just resigns this is just such an
aesthetically amazing pleasing advert
for the bayonet attack this game I'll
dear oh dear would you know I've done
one or two videos on my channel before
about Bayonetta because it's like I
didn't know yeah yeah yeah i don't know
i mean the i think the theoretical
status wasn't so um isn't so bad anyway
for black but i'm not sure what what you
should do against this line i am no
expert i'm no expert but i didn't think
that that black was doing so badly in
this opening I'm lady just theoretically
at least it means it's all its
everything is this also matter of taste
on it's not only objective evaluation
but also you need to like the position
but let's have a look-see okay let's
give an example here so so you did plan
with rook f6 then we crash free will
check wouldn't we or is there something
strong hair then hair up your 7s also
I'm roughly seven first to pimp in here
what's not bad by the way our resident
YouTube GM is talking about how pins are
sometimes not very good to use I think
this games got a lot of pins and
counters pins and see samples you know
that smirnoff he's talking about pins up
with Bishop g5 any idea I don't I don't
watch this video no but he's all his
examples back it up right but it's like
greater the virtual rule yeah but there
are counter examples i'm pretty sure but
here okay it's good to create this pin
for example in chess you can find
examples for everything i mean their
games one with one f3 also okay so say
say the Queen moves here this is even
worse so now you do the execution will
check check this is because you got
Bishop g6 now you're threatening mate
with Queen 87 yeah this wins I mean if
you're if you're if you're worried
check very para mania kind of person we
can also give this check yet so that's
even worse let's leave a much stronger
every piece I mean I it's winning Oh
everything's winning here hmm I mean
what could black do it could go here and
then you can you can decide I mean it so
you can take h5 but maybe this sounds so
clear I mean what what is why doing now
I mean d 7 is also hanging and it's no I
think you would need to oh no reason
busy Queens I me now i need to maybe
return which is still terrible for black
but it's questionable if this this this
pawn grab helped you so much Roy ever
you can make maybe you can just take
care yeah yeah hmm hard to say I with
the rook maybe with a rock hard to tell
I mean the rook I'm just having a sort
of a liability to the Queen yeah so
maybe it's an idea to move the rock and
then you have to this Queen edge 5 check
still coming up yeah out also now you're
threatening this one yeah rotate 6 g7
yes yes of course you just you just
basically uncover the titan i as well
yeah yeah I black has no move here let's
say move something like this go for it
example then you just can you just push
the a pawn maybe you can I mean f2 is
saying but maybe you can still just
would you get g6 is pretty if you if you
let black weaken g6 a with this so you
play check and play Bishop g6 isn't that
strong there's no killer check here is
that isn't this end the game Bishop g6
here probably check this one maybe check
check oh man there's a lot of resources
in chess isn't God oh I'm not not
winning with Queenie to hear check no
way maybe this one Oh blimey but I mean
this kind of variation I think you had a
position where Blake was very close to
just resigning I mean you resigned in
the game actually yes so maybe you don't
want to get there must be something
clearer maybe you don't want to want to
let him take on f2 and just play some
positional move okay so i think it was
quite justified to resign yes tutor is I
name so very nice demonstration from
prom nakia a bit frightening for the
Kings Indian players to be honest so
you're doing overview in summary so if
you want to play the Kings engine I
think you got to know something about
the bayonet attack this game shows
bayonet take the exploitable base of the
chain d 6 is exhilarating an attacking
principle on d6 rather than the base of
the chain here but just just just a
little thing just a little thing here if
you really play this as black and you're
sort of afraid of this move maybe it's
an idea to to to look for some some
other line may be here I'm late I played
86 myself is black to stop all this
night g5 stuff because it did scare me
just in my club games this I don't like
night g52 e6 why I've wasted time of h6o
some success I mean I mean a couple of
years ago I mean a five force also a
possibility which isn't too bad I think
I mean it's a more of a positional way
to to pray to play this um it usually
continuous like this here and then you
can sometimes you can play b62 trying to
hold wide a bit on the queenside yeah I
mean you're maybe slightly worse here
but it's not it's not so terrible ya
mean this is an idea or if you really
sort of don't care much about I mean
just want to have a fight young then you
can also just just play on I 28 here yes
and f5 and so on 197 maybe it's a like
like and nakamura did a couple of times
it's it's possibly objectively better
for white but very difficult to play I
mean I'm referring to to this kind of
stuff here now I think even she lost a
rep to Roger Berwick in this line when
this is this line we got a couple of a
kakeru Nakamura games he won against
galfond a brilliant game really I don't
know if you ever covered this but he did
an amazing kingside attack against
girlfriend he was black and he also won
against honored with this I mean from
from a lost position but yeah it's um I
mean if you play this kind of line with
black you sort of except that you might
be losing at some point but it's it's
very very dangerous all the time for
white also i mean this is a kind of
position i wouldn't play with both
colors well you swap the evil because
instead of the evil of having to chase a
pawn to regain a porn and lose your
bishop pair you accept being squashed
and demolished on the queenside instead
with some counter chances on the King
side here more with your bishop so yeah
it's dangerous I mean he'd spread from
practically in the practical chess game
it's is difficult to play for four wide
also mmm I mean I wouldn't play it as
white because it's a it just happened so
often that you get majored yes yeah I
saw a video once that Grandmaster yeah
melinski did for for icc and it was very
funny it was was doing a serious on the
king's indian and he showed one of his
games in this line actually and then he
sort of record his thoughts during the
game because he thought okay um why did
it play this line actually he I'm
sitting in the first round of a Swiss
against 2,000 player that might get
mated
and he didn't at the end but the yyy who
did I get into this year hmm so it's not
a kind of convenient position for y to
play like you can just press a bit and
here and there and trying to do
something without much risk this is just
here dude I am so so maybe black players
who are they exactly competing for the
World Championships might consider it
playing this because it's I mean on this
level it's very risky to do so but I
mean in Justin normal chess game where
you want to have some fun old so why not
go for this well the call rate was in
this game can i pick this this game was
a bad demo of the porn sack only six
yeah but like us so many many
alternatives also but to want you what
he could play I mean before I even just
to make some funny I even played King h8
in a couple of games as black when I
played to the Kings Indian let's black
up late King h8 a couple of times the
idea being this kind of this kind of
stuff yeah get rid of the dark square
Bishop huh yeah it's not it's not
brilliant or anything but I mean it's
playable and and come up with some some
interesting idea and then you can play
this opening why not okay so I was sort
of interrupting the llama Kings engine
player is gonna help my over the board
maybe I like kings engine remains a good
workhorse main club chess surely a
chilliness I mean so play it from time
to time as black if I'm in an
adventurous mood so to say this
convinces me I don't want to invite the
night 36 this game even more I actually
so no I don't I don't like blacks play
to chase back this porn and just be
positionally like it's just positional
porn sacrifice this Queen a4 afforded by
virtually no blacks Queen cannot do
anything as aggressive as Queen a for
it's quite interesting this this pawn
chain gives Queen a for such a punch on
black light squares
I find it fascinating that you know just
basically this is a very aggressive porn
change still okay this dis dis Brooke
move it's just totally not in the Kings
Indian spirit to be going over after
pawns like this on the queenside but
it's just the make sure it's just what
the position is from the opening yeah
it's really difficult I think at one
point there of course should be some
improvement I don't know what like I'm
not move 15 or something but it's it's
really difficult to play I mean I'm not
quite sure what what we shook prepared
there but it's way I think it's very
annoying to play over the board if only
if you think you you're under so much
pressure and it's it's far easier to
play for rioters get all this active
moves so sort of come naturally to you
what what the statistics on pawn shines
when one sign has to sort islands to
islands and one has free does the side
with more islands generally lose
statistically so I know that's an
abstract question would you say they
generally lose they got more weaknesses
to cover yeah I mean no spawn structures
of course always an issue but yeah now I
had to say it but it really depends on
the position yeah I know okay I know
it's like okay I'm all right i hope i
hope people on YouTube bum found some
I'll dual commentary bands are quite
interesting and informative so we'll
upload this to both all channels thanks
Chris thanks everyone for watching yeah
thanks for watching so comments or
questions on youtube on kingscrusher or
the chess explain channel okay thanks
very much